having to be in the courtroom when they
play the actual video
i literally had you know
it broke me um i was in tears and so
it was just a very emotional time
it's honestly worse than any horror
movie i've ever seen
in my life so it's difficult
to watch and knowing
him even just hearing his voice
and hearing his moans and his cries
i wasn't able to physically look at it
but just hearing
that was was tormenting it's hard to
watch
and how much have you felt racial
discrimination has played a part here in
what happened to george but also where
you are now in terms of this trial
his case has kind of transcended some of
the race issues
because it's more about humanity like
in this case if you had any human
feelings at all you felt something
when you saw what happened to him so in
a lot of ways i think
it's been an eye-opener for a lot of
people
how do you feel hearing the testimony of
the young black woman the teenager who
started rolling
on her mobile phone how do you feel
about her actions
you know there's there's not a word that
i can think of
to show her how grateful we are because
she was the one who
you know posted the video that everybody
around the world
saw initially and had it not been for
her
who knows we may not be where we are
today
obviously we want we want to see
the people who are responsible for his
murder to
to be held accountable and we want a
conviction
for those who are responsible also we
want to see
the kind of reform the actual change
in the police reform that will prevent
anybody else from having to
live out this same terror